وينضم الينا من كيف مراسل الجزيره حسن
مسعود وتنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله
الجزيره كارمن اهلا بكما وابدا معك حسن
مسعود اخر دعنه في سوره اخر التطورات
ميدانيا وسياسيا لو سمحت
عن النيه اوكرانيا استعاده كافه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه وفق قول الرئيس الاوكراني هذه
الزياره اتت ايضا بالتزامن مع عوده الرئيس
الاوكراني من تركيا الى اوكرانيا
وكان قد عاد
مصطحبا عدد من قاده كتيبه ازوف والمقاتلين
الذين كانوا يقاتلون في مصنع ازوف ستال في
مريوبل ايضا لذاك المصنع ولهؤلاء رمزيه
كبيره بالنسبه للاوكرانيين بعد ملحمه
شهدتها مدينه ماريوبل وكذلك مصنع ازوفستال
انتهت في منتصف مايو الماضي عبر عدد من
الاتفاقات من بين تلك الاتفاقات كان تسليم
هؤلاء لانفسهم للجانب الروسي وبعد ذلك كان
هناك تبادل في سبتمبر الماضي ولكن كان
هؤلاء قد توجهوا الى اوكرانيا ولم يسمح
لهم بالعوده عفوا الى تركيا ولم يسمح لهم
العوده الى اوكرانيا لكنهم الان عادوا مع
الرئيس الاوكراني الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
مجددا هذا كله يتزامن مع تطورات الميدانيه
المتسارعه والمستمره على طول جبهه القتال
الممتده من الشرق باتجاه اقصى الجنوب
نستمزج الموقف ايضا في موسكو مع كارمن
كارمن اخر التطورات ميدانيا وسياسيا ايضا
نعم خديجه العالم ظن انه طوى صفحه القنابل
العنقوديه بعد هذه الاتفاقيه التي وقعت
عليها 120 دوله قبل 15 عاما ولكن ملف
القنابل العنقوديه كان عنوانا اساس في
التصريحات السياسيه الروسيه بعد اعلان جو
بايدن الرئيس الامريكي عزمه وتقديم حزمه
من الاسلحه من ضمنها هذه الذخائر الاعتراض
الروسي اتى على لسان السفير الروسي لدى
واشنطن الذي اعتبر ان هذه الخطوه تقرب
البشريه من حرب عالميه جديده له ايضا
تصريح لمريض خروف المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه قالت ان هناك مسعا
لاطاله امد هذا الصراع ولكنها في الوقت
ذاته قالت خديجه ان هذه اجزاء خائر لن
تؤثر على مسار العمليه العسكريه وحذرت من
خطوره هذه الذخائر قالت انه ان وعودك يا
ابني واشنطن بانها لن تستخدمها في استهداف
المدنيين وانها لن تؤثر على المدنيين غير
حقيقيه هذا التصريح خديجه ايضا مرتبط
بتصريح اخر من انطونيو الذي قال واعرب عن
قلقه ازاء هذه الخطوه ودعا الى الالتزام
بهذه الاتفاقيه التي سبق ووقعت في وقت
سابق لماذا هذه التصريحات متتاليه هناك
مخاوف جديه من هذه الذخائر لانه وفق
الخبراء العسكريين اليوم يتحدثون عن الاثر
التدميري لهذه القذائف والاخطر من ذلك
يقولون ان نسبه كبيره من
القذائف داخل هذه القنابل لا تنفجر مباشره
اي انها تحتاج لوقت اطول وهذا يعني ان هذه
الذخائر من الممكن ان تنفجر لدى الوصول
لدى وصول المدنيين الى المناطق خديجه شكرا
جزيلا لكما ترمي موسكو وحسن مسعود من كيف